I think the major change have done in
the United States public opinion being
so deep in the quick sense of Iraq I
believe that the American public is far
less or would be far less tolerable to
any sort of a military action even a
limited one against against Iran the
u.s. is facing two fronts Afghanistan in
Iraq and I don't see the American public
very fond of a third one from the
Israeli point of view the only lesson
that was learned was only intelligence
by intelligence expert or intelligence
officers and this deals with a secret
report initiated by the committee for
Foreign Affairs and security of the
Parliament investigating how come Azrael
was part of the general view that Saddam
Hussein holds WMD and when reading the
classified report some of it coded in
the secret war with Iran I you would
think that it would be if it wasn't so
sad and gloomy it could have been very
funny there's even one story there about
an information received by Israeli
sources title not reliable or
questionable reliable and sent to the
United States as the regular discourse
in exchange of information from the
United States to Germany from Germany to
French intelligence services and then
back to Israel but without the
identification of its origin when it was
received in Israel it was seen as a
corroborated information and therefore
take highly reliable and recent to the
United States so by these look circles
of of information something that was
dimmi reliable becomes very reliable and
lead to the conclusion that was false
that saddam hussein hold stability
you